hello everyone and welcome back to the
clutch chess international we are
continuing with game 8 of the semi-final
match Magnus Carlsen versus Levin Aragon
and it's quite a game it's it's a
masterpiece basically so without further
ado let's let's check it out Magnus it
went to the white pieces opens with c4
he goes for the English and we have
Knight to f6 by 11 Knight to c3 and E 5
now striking in the center the two
Knights of the English variation and the
g3 now the Carlos Bremen system
preparing to fight for the b v square by
finn catering the delights for bishop we
have Bishop to b4 xi also fights for the
d5 square by trying the knight on c3
which defends the d5 square so it is
possible to let's say capture and then
execute d5 but magnus goes efore saying
that he really wants to control the d5
square and now you can't really capture
and capture because if you go for
something like this captures be captures
and denied tetris here just we need to
will force the knight back and you will
win back your phone even if you defend
it just b3 and you can still pick it up
so you don't really win upon that way
so after this efore move we have castles
by 11 and now knight GT 2 with d6 by 11
and now bishop the g2 is a move that has
been played before in a few games but h3
by Magnus is a new move so already has a
move 6 we have a completely new game so
11 continues developing with Knight to
c6 and now Bishop to G to Magnus also
prepares the castle and a6 now preparing
to strike on the Queen side with b5 we
have castles by Magnus and now B 5 B 5
is a very interesting point sacrifice
that white should not accept because if
you go for the pawn with Knight captures
on b5 Bishop to a6 is super annoying
here attacking the knight it's also on
the same diagonal as the rook on f1 so
after you go back you have ideas like
Bishop to d3 which would completely you
know slow down White's development and
this is not something you want to do for
the price of one point so especially in
a rapid game in a classical game you can
snatch up on and then suffer for 3 hours
and then
you know come on top but in a rapid game
not maybe not so much
so b5 and Magnus defense with the d3 we
have B captures on c4 we have D captures
on c4 again keeping control of the d5
square and Bishop back to c5 now and not
allowing Magnus any if for ideas but
Magnus already made room for the King on
h2 so he shifts it over to safety and
now in the future you can play f4 if you
need or f3 for that matter so rook to b8
putting pressure on the Queen side and
now b3 everything is nicely defended
here and now you're free to continue
developing we have a 5 if the knight
moves which it probably will it's coming
to d5 then you can maybe play a 4 and
create some weaknesses on the Queen side
Magnus goes for d5 now he has an
excellent outpost for his knight and a
for the Levin once the capture on b3
we've Bishop to e3 and 11 now just
captures a cat person b3a captures and
now even Bishop captures on e3 and while
you could capture with the night and
then shift the knight back to d5 Magnus
has different plans he captures with the
F pawn which opens up the F file for the
rook and also if black ever captures
here then you can undal easily by
playing it captures here so Knight to d7
and now with ideas of maybe going f5 to
open up his own rook
but now Knight eat the c3 by Magnus now
Magnus is going for Knight b5 which will
put a lot of pressure on c7 so Knights
the c5 also going for the b3 pawn now
with a double attack
and now Knights the b5 Magnus defends
the pawn by blocking the rooks attack to
the pawn and puts pressure on the c7
point and we have reached the position
from the thumbnail it's a similar
similar position not the position but
the placement of the Knights from the
game Murphy vs. Anderson that we've
covered but we might cover it again as
we're doing the morphe saga from the
beginning so now the c7 phone is under
attack and black needs to defend its
sunlight back to East six guards the
pawn and now h4 just gives a square DHT
3 squared to the white bishop and of
course you are playing
to h3 to attack one of the defenders of
the c7 square and then you are hoping to
gobble up that c7 pawn so Bishop to d7
and now Bishop to h3 now preparing to
just eliminate one of the defenders
so rook the b7 11 needs to add another
defender to the b7 pawn and now before
Magnus now opens up this diagonal so the
Queen can also enter the game however we
have Knight to e7 now hoping to trade
off some nights maybe even c6 will be an
idea with a double attack on both nights
but Magnus says no that's not a problem
he just plays rook to 8u and now it's
it's a very interesting position c6
doesn't really do anything since you can
always capture with the check and you
haven't really done anything that the d6
pawn also will be very weak so what you
could do is you could try and the trade
off some pieces however there's no way
to do it if you capture here then just
it captures on d5 this Knight is trapped
it has no squares where it can go so you
you just lose a piece here now on the
other hand after this rook to eight you
move Magnus is just planning to double
up and there's a very little black can
do here for example if you try Bishop
characters on b5 it's really no better
just see capture some b5 and you're
still without a good good move if you
try and grab the pawn then you get
Bishop characters and e6f captures and
now rook captures on f8 with check queen
Queen captures and now Knight captures
on c7 with check rook captures on B for
a now Queen captures and b6 and now all
of these pawns will fall and well once
the rook to e8 comes is just a terrible
position for black so not not much you
can do here
so instead after rook to a 211 played
Knight to c8 probably with the idea that
he just wants to repeat 97-98 and see
what Magnus will do or maybe he wants to
shift the night over to b6 to put
pressure on c4 and under Knight from
there however this now loses the game
and feel free to pause the video and try
to find it this winning idea while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on putting black in
suits wonk and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
it's rook to a eight and now you see
that black really doesn't have any moves
you cannot move the rook if you move the
rook from the defense of the pawn then
just Bishop characters and white will
capture on c7 and the other moves aren't
much better and the point that rook to
eight is so strong is because if Bishop
captures nb8 then you win with rook
captures on c8 Queen captures and 97
check now just picks up the Queen so
that's only one of the problems after
rook to e8 so Levin basically you can
move the rook the King and maybe Quinta
I ate so Levin played King to h8 but now
Magnus brings the Queen into the game
Queen to h5 and now even though you move
the King away from check you still don't
have a way of capturing for example if
you capture on b5 group characters and
f7 is extremely strong you've removed
one of the defenders of the night here
and after characters captures you're
just completely lost here you still
can't move the knight this is just
terrible
this is hanging so not not much you can
do here so after this Queen to h5 move
with Queen to 811 adds another defender
to the f7 point but now Bishop the f5
threatening checkmate and again the
problem is you cannot play g6 because
after g6 you get Queen to h6 check and
again not not much you can do here
Knight to f6 is coming and that's it
even if you capture Knight f6 still wins
there's no defense against Jeff made so
after Bishop f5 we have h6 preventing
checkmate this way but now a brilliancy
move from Agnes Bishop to h3 Bishop to
h3 puts black in complete soup swung
there is no again there is no move you
can make here like you could move some
pawns or maybe you can make some silly
moves but and no piece can move here and
again the point of this position is that
Bishop captures and b5 is never an
option for example in Bishop characters
and b5 here do you see how white wins
now it's very interesting so even feel
free to pause the video and try and find
it while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on being an expert on
the kingside attacks and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
it's rook captures and c8 but not just
real characters in theater but Queen
captures here and now rook to f6 gets
the job done the thread is rook captures
on h6 after captures captures with check
you're gonna get Knight to f6 or if the
rook is captured just Queen captures
King g8 in the knight to f6 now delivers
checkmate
so that's how beautiful this position is
so black has no moves so Levin played c6
but now everything just falls apart the
d6 pawn has now been weakened so Magnus
captures it and now there's a double
attack on the night also the Queen is
under attack
so Knight captures on d6 and there is no
there is no move you can play it's just
just a terrible position if you try
something like Queen to d8 then you just
give up the rook on b7 so you're just
giving up more material so instead 11
just decided to give up the Queen for
some material and the Magnus said okay
rook captures we have rook captures on
e8 and now Knight to f6 again just
busting through the position still the
idea is the same the knight cannot be
captured and now rook to e7 adds more
defense to f7 but c5 now removing one of
the defenders of the f7 pawn Knight to
c4 and now with a beautiful finish
Knight captures on d7 Ruby captures and
e7 and now rook captures on f7 again
removing the defender of the night and
that's just it
11 played rook captures we have Bishop
captures on e6 with a triple attack now
and there is nothing to be done
rook to f2 check was played but after
King to h3 it was in this position that
11 RNN resigned at the game and Magnus
wins game 8 off their clutch
international match so here you resign
because you either give up the night or
the rook so obviously we're gonna give
up the night and after Bishop captures
you only have two rooks for a queen and
the bishop which is no compensation so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I was very very impressed with with how
black was in complete soups wrong with
all
the pieces on the board I really enjoy
when something like this happens so hope
you enjoyed that as well and yeah
Magnus won his match against Levin and
Fabiano Khurana won his match against
Wesley so so in the finals today we will
have Magnus Carlsen versus Fabiano
Caruana like we did in the former World
Chess Championship match so it's gonna
be it's gonna be really awesome and
we're probably gonna cover a bit more
games from that match so once again I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank you Jake Jang Andrew driver Jakob
Gonzales Peterman and Thomas Jenkins for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
clutch International finals checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your weekend